well the argument Boris Johnson was
always that the Tories needed a winner
but they hadn't won a majority for 23
years and I needed a kind of
unconventional politician if they were
going to do that that always been
obviously took a big blow on election
day when the Tories did win the majority
it is then taken another blow with the
election of Jeremy Corbyn its labor
leader suggesting that it always don't
you take any risks to win the next
direction adding to this is that Boris
at the moment is betwixt in between he's
an MP but his day job has been mayor of
london he's in the political cabinet but
not the actual cabinet and I think Boris
is struggling to work out how to kind of
carve out a political role for himself
at the moment he is also despite it's
got a very genial personality he's not
the most naturally club herbal person
and I don't think he's yet I found his
feet in the Commons again both in the
chamber and in the kind of tea room and
all the other social places that matter
so much in Westminster politics
well George Osborne is is a politician
transformed you know in the 2010 general
election campaign he felt the need to
shut himself away in party HQ he didn't
think he was much an electro asset for
the Tories in 2012 his political career
always came to an end when his budget
unraveled but now he is the pilot who
has weathered the economic storm you
know he is touring the world viewed as
Prime Minister presumptive by foreign
governments and he has this quite
awesome network of support for the
people who were his parliamentary
private secretaries in the last
Parliament now sit around the cabinet
table he has more patronage I think than
anyone else in Tory politics
well Nicky Morgan is is the first of a
22 in take to make clear publicly but
they are thinking about running for the
leadership in an interview with
spectator this week she makes clear that
if I family circumstances permit she
would like to run and that she thinks
that there should be a female candidate
now some people will say oh she only
became an MP five years ago she's far
too inexperienced but I think Nicky
Morgan has a a history of being
underestimated by people and also as we
reveal the spectator this week David
Cameron wants to carry on as prime
minister until 2019 and the idea is he
would announced he was leaving in the
spring of that year with the new tour
either then being unveiled at the party
conference that autumn that gives Nicky
Morgan quite a long time to establish
herself in the public mind and got to
remember that the 2010 and taker the
largest biggest single group in the Tory
parliamentary party and if they start
swinging behind the candidate that
candidate will be quite a formidable
presence I also think that Nicky Morgan
is going to try and run as the candidate
of a kind of centre-left of a Tory party
in this context it's very interesting
that she is clear that she is absolutely
no doubt which size she'll be on come be
EU referendum
well enjoy the conference is going to be
an interesting mix because on the one
hand it's a victory lap for David
Cameron I think the official slowly over
the conference is security stability and
opportunity the David Cameron it could
really be summed up in one word
vindication he turns up as the first
Tory to win a majority in 23 years and
that that's quite something but on the
other hand will also see the beginnings
of the maneuverings for the leadership
contest that is to come I mean one thing
to watch boys who says water on Europe
I'm at the moment the polls show that in
and out are much closer than they have
been and but a majority of Tory voters
are leaning towards out but I'm own
every single one of a candidate or
leadership appears to be on the inside
of this debate watch to see if anyone
makes any movement on that